je révolution et et de cuisiniers et
cuisinières chef de cuisine qui a marqué
toute une époque qui a marqué une
génération dans dans son mode de travail
dans son fonctionnement dans sa rigueur
et son amour des produits pour tous
cuisiniers ça dure côtoyé joël robuchon
c'est une façon de maîtriser sa
profession mais surtout de donner une
dimension vraiment et existentielle dans
sa vomissure je vous jure que je suis
entré que je suis en fait à paris
j'avais 23 ans et je suis entré au
relais faire avec honda durant et c'est
un très bon ami de michel decugis où
l'on dira et c'est ces deux hommes
et les années 80 85 et 90 ont manqué par
ida dans leur façon de travailler